how can we optimize ourselves personally
to live the happiest healthiest longest
life possible what does that look like
what ways of doing that what are
unethical ways of doing that you know
where are the slippery slopes I'm Nick
Gillespie and today I'm talking with
Jane Metcalf she's a co-founder of Wired
magazine and the co recipient of the
very first landing friedlander prize
from Reason Metcalfe's new Accenture is
neo dot Life a website that chronicles
what she calls the Neo biological
revolution the many ways that technology
medicine and new forms of knowledge are
radically expanding human longevity and
the quality of life Jane thanks for
talking thanks for inviting me what are
the main facets of the neo biological
revolution the basis of neo life is that
computer science and engineering
thinking has invaded biology what are
the similarities what are the
differences and how do we think about
biology and human life differently if we
start thinking about code you know we
discovered DNA back in the 50s you know
in the early aughts we learned how to
read the code now we're learning how to
write the code how does that change
things human beings have been evolving
forever the difference is the rate of
acceleration and something very very
specific which is our ability now to
edit the human genome and to edit not
just what's happening in our own bodies
now but to pass those edits on to
subsequent chip and that's germline
engineering where it's like we can
change what our bodies are and
everything that comes out of exactly
recent pieces on the site common theme
seems to be individual empowerment one
piece is called power to the patient's
and it's about a guy who has cancer and
it's fighting through certain aspects
another is called women finally get the
fertility tests they deserve why is
power shifting towards patients towards
women towards individuals what what is
what is going on there well two things
really one is that so much of our
existing system is just broken in the
case of the man who's the power to the
patients he's got a rare disease he's
got a rare genetic mutation maybe 10,000
people in America a hundred thousand
people worldwide that may not be enough
to justify a pharmaceutical investment
in research to address
his problem that's called an orphan
disease and it's just the kind of just
left dealing with the symptoms and so in
today's day and age you can sequence
your genome you can sequence the genome
of your tumors and you can start to use
the tools of Big Data and artificial
intelligence machine learning to try and
see patterns and correlations and
ultimately causations that can help you
understand not only what's causing the
disease but also potentially which drugs
could best address the disease it seems
it's all of a piece as well I mean in
every other aspect of our lives where
we're moving from kind of mass to niche
yeah so we don't all drink the same
coffee we don't all dress the same
anymore we can get personalized this and
that so why not that's right and there
may have been you know a handful of
artisanal coffee brands you know that
kind of made it on a national scale but
there's I can't even imagine how many
thousands of coffee brands now and they
may be very localized and that may be
enough to support their brand it's not a
women's site but it very much speaks to
women as well as men a lot of political
stuff a lot of medical stuff assumes a
masculine audience for a long time it
seemed like in the medical space women
were kind of told to shut up and just
sit there while doctors worked on it's
because women were considered small men
female astronauts talked about being
given suits that were size small for men
well there's some very fundamental
differences there women need drugs in
different quantities they may need
different drugs entirely and so what
happens when women are the doctors when
women are the researchers when women are
running the companies you know it turns
out you get better products for women
that is well and it's interesting that
like in primatology and whatnot for a
long time all you know all of the early
primatologists were mostly men or if
they were women you know but they all
looked at the male chimps and then it's
like something is odd when you look at
oh well look at you know female chimps
they have their own behavior as well
that's just kind of an interesting catch
up I mean one of the things I like about
the site is that it's not about men or
pretending that men are the universal
subject that it includes much more than
that I mean I see so many women at the
leading edge of developments in health
and medicine and you know biology and
the JPMorgan health conference that just
took place you know the big takeaway
there was that there were more men named
Mike speaking than there were female CEO
speaking I mean it was just the numbers
are crazy and you know at the power
structures that the largest companies
that's still the case but what I look at
is where's the energy where the emergent
companies the emergent technologies the
emergent researchers you know where are
the companies that are addressing unmet
needs and so many of those are being run
by women you recently interviewed craig
Venter who famously sequenced the human
genome and did it yep more quickly and
cheaper than than a government program
to do that which was working in parallel
technically it was a tie yes but well
the money was cheaper but in any card
you know on his side but one of the
things he's talking about which is
really kind of exciting and bizarre to
think about is a $5,000 check up that
will detect zero stage cancer the first
time I read that I was like okay you
know how do you even know it's there if
it has an you know move past zero stage
he says in the interview that it's
something like 5% of people over 50 have
some kind of life-threatening cancer or
condition that they don't even know
about and so this $5,000 checkup could
save your life is that kind of stuff you
know is it going to and I guess this is
a selfish question a long way is this
stuff gonna become cheap enough and
ubiquitous enough and effective enough
rapidly I mean like is this happening
now or is this all kind of you know in
10 years or 20 years or 30 so human
longevity Inc had a program called the
human the the health nucleus it's still
called the nucleus used to cost $25,000
now you're getting almost all of that
for 5,000 so it initially costs two
billion dollars to sequence the human
genome then they got it down to a
hundred twenty-five million you know
then they got it down to twenty-five
thousand now there's a company that'll
sequence to your whole genome for $1,000
and that it's just you know it's like
the cost of a cell phone call so you're
saying I should wait yeah if you don't
reticular you could wait because I do
think those prices are falling rapidly
you know the question that a lot of
people have is is is coming up with
things that might never actually
manifest and so you know there's a
phrase for it it's called incidental
omma yeah you know it's the tumor you
get that might never develop into
something that threatens your health in
any way so are we overreacting are we
treating things that
you know in other circumstances we would
wait for symptoms on the other hand if
people are finding tumors if people are
finding risk of heart disease and other
things then there's things that you can
do to help you know prevent those things
from developing where do you fall on the
kind of scale of like unbridled human
intervention into the stuff of life
versus a more cautious approach and
Venter himself is you know he's both
obviously at the forefront of this but
he's also a little bit nervous about
some of the interventions we might make
because you know in a recent story or
maybe not so recent but you at neo life
was about the the Frankenstein story and
the gold stories well we ever get past
that idea that we we should not be
messing with our own genes or with our
own life well I think there's a big
difference then you could draw a great
big difference line between collecting
the information and doing something
about it and so right now we're going to
collect the information phase and if
you're paying $5,000 you're paying a
premium for something that's gonna cost
a little bit less you know soon it's
sort of the early adopter premium but
there's another reason for doing it
which is establishing a baseline and
then there's a third reason for doing it
which is you are advancing the science
and you know they may find something in
your genome that can help unlock a
secret or a mystery and you know you get
the benefit of sort of you know peek
into what could potential happen in the
second half of your life have you had it
done I have and did you find anything
like I'm not I'm not the person I
thought I was I know I'm a Supreme Being
and that's pretty much what my genome
tells me however there were a few things
that had I known them before I had
children I would have sweated about it
throughout my entire pregnancy so I'm
just too soon I'm glad I waited you know
a friend of mine is a swimmer and she
found out she had stage zero
esophageal cancer which is apparently a
risk for swimmers who are inhaling
chlorine all the time so she did
intervene and she's glad for it you know
craig venter himself found prostate
cancer that's also something that's good
too to do early would it not have
advanced who knows I think it's those
are individual decisions I just think
having the power is what's important
wired is turns 25 this year right this
19 this month in January of 2018 as much
as it chronicled the digital revolution
it also kind of heralded it and helped
created what it is is there a continuity
between what you were doing at Wired and
what you're doing now at neo life
absolutely absolutely
in the same way that Wired didn't just
cover the technology we're not just
covering the science we want to cover
all the aspects around it there are a
lot of cultural responses to this stuff
I mean you can see this explosion of
television shows and movies and books
about you know AI and robots and you
know what happens when we start editing
our genome and so forth you know there's
huge ethical moral and ethical
conversations that need to take place
there are design issues if we're gonna
start editing ourselves our species well
then what would we like that to look
like and so let's throw it it's like
early computers everything will be putty
color yeah exactly and we don't have to
wait maybe 20 years to get colorful
computers and sold on the basis of fear
uncertainty and doubt right that FUD
factor is what drove everybody to buy
IBM you know it's like if we drive
everybody to do something because
they're afraid of what's in their genome
that's quite different than if we focus
on how can we optimize ourselves
personally to live the happiest
healthiest longest life possible to be
as smart as we possibly can and to carry
that forward to our children you know
what does that look like what ways of
doing that what are unethical ways of
doing that you know where are the
slippery slopes so I want Neel life to
be not again like wired not just
covering the science of the technology
but covering the broader issues but also
keeping touch with you know that leading
edge because it's so incredibly
[Music]
you